I'm a nassif Gann I'm the Associate
Director for innovation and strategic
partnerships for the Scott Institute for
energy innovation we are very glad to
have you here for this lunchtime lecture
I am NOT doing the formal introduction
today but I am here for a bit of
housekeeping in front of you on the
table you'll actually see a note about a
website that we're using to collect
questions so if you have a question for
one of our for either our speaker or our
moderator you can certainly put that
information you put slide o comm into
your browser you put in the code pound C
mu energy which is the same as all of
our social media in the case you're
doing that today and the questions will
come to the moderator on stage so with
that I'd like to introduce Christine
Monde or she is a CMU alum a CMU adjunct
professor and she's also the principal
and co-founder of evolve EA which is an
architecture and planning firm here in
Pittsburgh Thank You Christine thanks
Anna so I have the pleasure today of
introducing the CEO of philips lighting
chris white and to come on home if i can
tell you a little bit about chris
exactly but i thing and how becomes
chris white is the fairly recently named
president of the americas president
emeritus for philips lighting and he's
responsible for accelerating the
company's leadership position and
expanding the role of the region is a
critical hub of economic growth and
innovation if I understand correctly you
managed all commercial and operational
activities across the company's entire
portfolio from conventional and LED
products to connected systems and
services and to advance the success of
Philips in North South and Central
America big region you are a recognized
thought leader on the positive
disruptive effects on the increasingly
digital and connected world
has done a TED talk online I recommend
and he brings a unique perspective to
the Internet of Things which is helping
the company further expand its connected
lighting offerings Chris has held a
number of transformative executive roles
throughout his career prior to joining
philips Lighting he was a 20-year
veteran of Cisco where he held various
leadership roles including senior vice
president of global sales strategy and
go to market the Internet of Things
where he spearheaded Cisco's market
influence and leadership in IOT and
before that he was the general manager
of sports and entertainment group which
under his leadership grew from a 20
million dollar company to a 500 million
dollar business in less than five years
so with that let's hear from Chris thank
you thank you good afternoon and great
to see everybody it's a amazing
experience to be here at Carnegie Mellon
thank you for that great introduction
it's always I as I hear you know your
bio I'm like is that really me I'm like
so hopefully I can live up to that
expectation so in the next 15 minutes my
objective is to hopefully change your
perspective of light and one kind of
corny way I could do it is turn the
lights off and do this presentation in
the dark and share the value of light
but I think you will get that but light
and the whole lighting industry is going
through yet another amazing
transformational journey a lot of people
get the fact that old incandescent
lighting that philips has been a pioneer
and innovator for over a hundred and
twenty years in has gone through its
first major transition going to LED
lights and most of us see the value and
understand what LEDs can do for us from
a longevity perspective and a quality of
light however now that entire ecosystem
is being connected and for someone that
has been in the industry in the world of
IOT for the last couple of years some of
you probably know some of the
predictions already we all feel fairly
connected to the Internet today however
the predictions are 20 billion 50
billion maybe 200 billion things
are being connected to the Internet over
the next three to five years and on the
one hand that sounds crazy amazing and
that you know is that even possible but
then every day in taxi cabs around the
worlds in conversations over dinner
my son has a connected basketball my
father-in-law has connected hearing aids
we all have connected thermostats many
of you hopefully have connected lighting
at your home through our success in the
consumer channel with with the hue
product which is the number one
connected product around a lexer as an
example so voice-activated lighting but
I want to give you a lighting tour here
of the lighting world is this today I
want to share with you some of the
innovation of the future and I do want
to achieve two things one get you
thinking differently about light but I
also would challenge you all to start
acting differently about light because
if we're really going to all take
advantage of this thing called IOT or
digitization or connected lighting we've
got to do certain things a little
differently and as you go through this
presentation and as we get into the QA
hopefully you'll kind of be thinking
about that as we turn this into a
discussion not just a one-way
conversation but a couple of data points
right light it's an interesting dilemma
so light is a major consumption of power
around the world probably the largest
18% of the world's energy is consumed
through light sources so there's a huge
amount of pressure to reduce the amount
of energy that light consumes yet there
is exponential demand for a light right
so so the predictions is more as the
population this planet grows those are
actually one sobering data point there's
1.2 billion people that don't have
access to regular energy or light
sources so there's a huge demand just
there but as the whole world urbanized
is we're looking at more and more light
sources hitting the world so therefore
thinking through the energy implications
the social implications the building
implications are not to be
underestimated this is a little bit of
I'm a mom and I'm an exercice you have
an ex Brits oh I'm an ex California and
I'm moving to the East Coast with
philips Lighting this I don't know
anyone recognize where that bridge is
around the world any Californians in the
room
baybridge thank you that is the Bay
Bridge that got lit up actually
interesting ly enough through my
background with a Cisco data center and
a philips lighting infrastructure on the
one hand got phenomenal recognition
great lighting up another iconic tourist
place but also there's a little bit a
bit of bit of anxiety in that community
as well you know this homeless people in
San Francisco there are some urban
issues in San Francisco
should you be investing in a tourist
area so what we did was partner with the
city and actually si P and have come up
with a social media tracking device on
this device so the city can actually see
how many tweets Instagram social media
images or activations are used both in a
positive light and a negative light are
people tweeting this says what a waste
of money and this is terrible
are they taking photos saying oh my god
what a beautiful icon I'm going to come
back to San Francisco and thank goodness
that the positive feedback has been very
good and they're using that as a way to
help understand how they can connect
with the community understand what
tourism needs are for the future but
it's just an example of the idea of just
lighting a structure up is pretty cool
understanding what impact it has on
society or a community let alone the
economics of a community hopefully is
even more impactful and better to get a
little excited and hopefully to let let
lunch digest a little bit I want to
share with you a little bit of a video
we're so excited of this digital
transformation we're actually going to
change the name of our company next
month and this is a bit of a teaser on
that with regard to if I can get the Vig
okay she told me that's it the wiggle
the finger no I got that I missed the
wiggle of finger piece I got it okay so
hopefully the audio will come through as
well playing this very short short video
that will share with you a little bit of
what the transformation is all about
one more time can I can do this wiggle
your finger press the play button that's
what I did
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you there's a village people in
the room that started clapping first by
the way so it was just just to clarify
what that means we're actually keeping
our brand names right you using the
Philips brand in certain areas still but
from a company perspective philips
Lighting spun off from Royal Philips
almost its two-year anniversary is
coming up next month as an example so
we're the largest publicly-traded
lighting company in the world today
I've got a very five percent to spend an
investment on R&D we believe the
combination of innovation in lighting
and combining that with the value and
impact of connected lighting has
tremendous impact on this world and in
business in general
hence the hence the name change which
will become official next month after it
goes through a little bit of European
legislative issues so let's talk about
why our world is changing I think some
of this is no no surprise at all to this
great audience here obviously a
population growth means people need more
light light there is also though a
challenge of how much that resource is
consuming therefore how can you make it
even more efficient and energy efficient
and use less of the resources that are
out there to make sure this planet keeps
going but then also there's the idea of
what does digital innovation do to that
as things digitally go from analog to
digital I think we all know the rate of
change changes dramatically it's not
just a linear change it's an exponential
change and sometimes we all have trouble
getting our heads around probably not
with this esteemed audience but I do
thinking about how do you think and act
exponentially how do you plan for
exponential change our architects our
design people our buildings our arts are
set you know beautiful building just
down the road is a multi-year process by
the time that building starts compared
to when people walk into that building
the technology has changed dramatically
so how do we think differently an
architect differently and collaborate
differently to take advantage of that I
wanted to give you a couple of few
examples of that obviously the
population growth and urbanization with
cities is putting a lot of pressure on
city infrastructure how could light and
the
infrastructure help transform that I
know we have the mayor of San Juan here
I just had a meeting with her this
morning phenomenal passion and desire to
help get that community in that country
out of the tough times it had off to the
hurricane but she's also thinking
through as a thought leader of how do
you take advantage of that and put in a
digital infrastructure how do you put in
a connected infrastructure that if that
terrible accident happens again how do
you how do you how do you how do you get
how do you get back online quicker how
do you get lighting to communities
quicker how do you get power to
communities quicker how to get food to
connect it so this whole idea of
connecting communities that typically
operate in silos is a great area well
we're excited about is think of the
light infrastructure both inside a
building and outside the building I
spent 20 years at a networking company
that was pretty proud of plumbing the
internet and putting together the first
generation of the Internet and the great
impact that had think now of the next
generation whether you call it IOT or
digitization the need for connecting the
world with 5g technology that the telcos
and people are some people are excited
about I know some people are a little
nervous about that
5g as an example needs 10 times the
density of cell towers than the current
cellular technology so you think about
the impact that might have on a
beautiful campus like this you know do
you want to see 10 times the amount of
ugly cell towers designed as poor poor
poor imitations of plastic trees around
this campus as an example and what we've
tried to do is innovate and partner with
other other other private entities and
we've announced a partnership with this
company called 88 ICI American Tower
corporation American Tower corporation
their last business model was designing
those ugly towers but typically they're
in areas with not many people see we've
now designed a light pole that actually
can be beautifully our tech Arctic
architectural II designed but you can
open that light bulb up and put 5g
antennas or low-band IOT Internet towers
or Wi-Fi Wi-Fi antennas into the
structure and therefore cover to cover
the area without impacting the community
etc the efficiency side obviously is
is doings Philips are ourselves we have
shipped two billion LED light sources
already and that's made a difference but
then there are certain consumption
issues or infrastructure issues that how
do you keep going and how do you
actually get to that next generation of
what connecting light can really be all
about and how do you make an even bigger
impact with that so I wanted to kind of
share with you some examples of what
digital innovation is already happening
and I want to finish on hopefully
stretching your thoughts about future
waves of innovation that can leave we
haven't even figured out how to how to
implement and benefit from yet so let's
start at the home anyone here have a
connected lighting system in their home
today
few early adopters in the room let's get
the here right and the idea of connected
connected lighting and connected home
right it's not actually new right the
smart home has been talked about for
decades right Sony and Panasonic of this
world you know a couple of decades ago
got all excited about it and technology
wasn't together then the home networking
market that I was a part of a couple of
years ago Cola excited about it but now
with things like Alexa and nest
thermostat and connected lighting it's
becoming a reality you can actually use
your cell phone device to control your
home and I want to kind of stretch your
thinking a little bit because some
people in the audience are probably
sitting there saying you know seriously
you need a connected light bulb you
can't get up and turn the light switch
on enough but there are multiple
benefits of a connected lighting system
in the home one actually is safety and
security if you think about it right you
know how many people have tried that
gorgeous system of getting one of those
a timers in your wall and putting a
thing when you go on vacation right you
know I got a news flash right the
criminal world has figured out you know
if they sit outside your house for two
days in a row and that light bulb just
goes on and off you're not home right so
the idea or the connected system is why
not mimic it the way you live in that
home so set a patent that says when I
come home the lights in the kitchen go
on because it because I'm making making
dinner then I'm going to go to the front
room and watch TV for an hour then that
light is going to go off and I'm going
to the bedroom for half an hour and I'm
in bed and it gives the impression of a
more secure livable livable room think
about any one of us that have elderly
parents if you could help control the
lighting environment so as it gets dark
you can turn the lights on for your
elderly elderly
relations and improve the environment
they live in the idea of this has gone
into the hospitality area right anyone
that travels around the world one of the
worst things in them is is to get up in
the middle of the night hit the light
switch and be blinded and woken up when
you're trying to just survive through
the night and get as much sleep as
possible well certain new hospitals have
put sorry new hotels putting senses in
the room now so as you get up but a dull
light comes on you can go to the
bathroom you can turn the lights air
conditioning up or down you go back to
bed and relax so the spectrum is huge
the other end for any entertainments any
sort of Netflix junkies any movie buffs
in the room so we demonstrated at CES
where this can connect to your
entertainment system so the idea is pick
your favorite movie you gonna watch your
movie right you dull the lights every
most people now I've got these beautiful
TVs with surround sound systems what if
the lighting system interacted with that
movie what if we and we demonstrate this
with Wonder Woman right you're sitting
in a dark room watching a movie as an
explosion goes off all your lights go
off is what would go on as well the
immersive experience is incredible any
music people if you're listening to your
favorite band in a concert the light
show in your house is exactly the same
as what is going on in stage so there's
these two huge extremes it's a very
pragmatic practical example and then
there's this very inspirational
immersive entertainment value but let's
bring it back into the business world
and into into into buildings like this
this is Deloitte's corporate
headquarters in in in the Benelux
actually and talks about a connected
lighting system but they didn't just
connect the light system they gave every
employee an app to be able to control
that system so you can control the
lighting or in the environment this is
proved to be one of the most sustainable
buildings in Europe it's also proved to
be one of the most efficient buildings
in Europe and people like the
environment because you can adjust the
lighting to increase the energy level
and increase the productivity of people
in that in that area city of LA went to
a connected lighting system I've seen a
10% reduction in crime because guess
what crime happens in dark unsecured
neighborhoods so if you can increase the
lighting area in in the cities things
improve
Huntington Beach is an early pioneer
this is one of those light poles that I
talked about before right embedded in
that light bulb is a 5g antenna a wife
via a Wi-Fi antenna a shot detection
antenna an environmental antenna to
create a better environment in a
community to finish on a little bit to
think a little bit different and some of
the future technologies so solar-powered
light we've worked with areas in India
in some of the light starved villages so
kids can do their homework at night if
actually work done in South America to
provide light to Stadium so kids can
play soccer in the evenings there's this
great technology we just showed last
week at a light and Bill - two weeks ago
called life I life I uses the power of
light to distribute the Internet at the
moment it's being demonstrated a 30 to
40 megabyte pace so the idea of that
light source that delivers Wi-Fi and
data to that table
it doesn't distribute it everywhere so
it's very secure it's very focused
future technologies on infrared say that
could be up to three gigabits type of
transmission but also with this lighting
infrastructure you should be able to
tell how many people are in this room
what they're doing linking with the
infrastructure to adjust the
air-conditioning as a retailer you can
figure out where you are in the store
and deliver 30 centimeter location
accuracy using light versus other
technologies and then the other thing
we've got to do where I'll finish on is
we have to feed this world so light put
light sources and the way we use
horticultural lighting to make things
grow as efficiently and as effectively
as impossible hopefully as allows us to
feed the world as well so in that
lightning recession there I know we want
to turn this into an interactive session
so I'll come join you on the couch thank
you for listening hopefully you do think
of lighting a little bit differently and
I'll come join you what do you want to
say all right well let's give him hand
first
so I get to pick your brain a little bit
and so I'm gonna ask this know much
there so be careful short short session
ok that's great we're done I'm gonna ask
you some questions about how Phillips is
thinking about these things not just
from a product aspect but also from how
you do business yep
connected back to how the university
connects and then talk about kind of how
this scales in the future so first we've
heard some interesting ideas about
change models um in the past
presentations yesterday and the day
before I'd say if I had to paraphrase
how people talked about it some people
talked about their company's is kind of
virtuous innovators other ones are
profit driven implementers crisis
disruption is another model of change
code driven change you know there's a
number of different ways that companies
are thinking about or researchers are
thinking about how their their offerings
are going to be taken up in the market
how where does fitz phillips fit in this
continuum and how do you all think about
yeah it's it's a great great question
and actually i think it's it's it's the
right question too because you know
being a publicly traded company now
there are certain pressures on you to
deliver results and continue to be
successful but hopefully that doesn't
distract you from your core values and
your on your core focus and one of
phillips Lighting's core values and
focus is innovation in lighting and the
benefit of lighting and so I'm actually
pretty proud and I don't have anybody
here at 90 days type thing but the the
balance seems to be a very good one and
hopefully the the pressure of being a
private sector company can put the right
sort of pressure on the innovation
engine because more and more that
innovation needs to be aligned with the
needs of a community or the business
otherwise it's not commercially viable
yeah so I think hopefully I think we've
got a we got a pretty good balance
on that you know we don't want to just
innovate for innovations sake yeah but
we're trying to make sure it's it's it's
it's it's a benefit to the planet and
the commercial side as well as the
educational side so if your change model
is is is you know connected to both
community and to product innovation into
profit obviously as well how is that
happening internal and I'll I'll say one
of the great things about Carnegie
Mellon is that you know we have people
from all different disciplines I'm an
architect and designer and thinking
about how people make urban environments
but I was talking to one of my
colleagues 10 years ago who was working
in material science and she's talking
about boy you know we're just we need to
get to this point before these cool
things she's doing which eventually led
to led um just weren't there yet and so
we recognized there was a gap between
what we're we were here who is Philips
is kind of that the organization right
now that's filling that gap right
between material science and
implementation who is on the team in
Philips
who what kind of thinking are you doing
how is this different than your
traditional model of doing business
because you're selling your bulbs in a
computer store not in a hardware store
yeah
no boy there's multi dimensions to that
question it's a great one you know I
think one if you look at the internal
side of a company like Philips
we now have multiple layers of where we
both innovate and interact with the
market and this is why I love doing
events like this right you know that the
challenge do you think differently and
keep up to date with an amazing
Institute's like this as far as how much
outreach they want to do how much
private partnerships do you want to
really roll your sleeves up and doing
but you know in certainly with regard to
Philips though we have you know a chief
innovation officer that is looking a
little further out you know looking all
around the world in China and India in
the u.s. in Europe to figure out what
are some of the new technologies and
disruptive factors that are happening
whether it be in in lighting innovation
or chip innovation or artificial
intelligence or robotic implementation
right those that those are colliding
when it comes to a a regional basis we
try and roll us
leaves up with both customers education
and again an innovation engine whether
it be a startup community that got very
well profile here this week and make
sure we're not missing anything and so
the the multi dimensions now we want to
make sure we're not so proud of our
heritage and innovation that we get
stuck into the good ol not invented here
syndrome but then you know it's a very
very very careful balance actually I
think nowadays but but but what I
thought what if comfortable with them
one of the reasons I joined the company
is I like the idea of you know let's
let's let's stick to our knitting so to
speak and realize there's so much
innovation going on in lighting and
disruption going on there and then let's
not be naive to what digital disruption
does so therefore as an example we've
launched an IOT platform with open API
is to other people so they can you know
plug into that community and both by the
way on the on the on the corporate side
as well as the home side so we have a
whole developer community for called
Friends of hue that can come up with
cool applications to use lighting that
you know we would never have come up
with without that ecosystem and
community yeah so you really need to
create that ecosystem to support your
product which is so much more complex
than when it was just providing lighting
it is I don't more other points I think
it's a very valid one right you know
lighting in a computing store and one of
our one of our challenges we move
digitally is the consumption of lighting
at the moment because historically we
typically would have gone to you know a
major building supplier or you know our
standard electrical play and all of a
sudden it does need to be in a
computerized environment and take that
into the business world and your
background of design and architecture
right it's like okay how do we talk
differently to the architectural
community and the design community to
think differently about you know it's
not just you know 6,000 light points in
this room right what could you do with
you know 8,000 connected ones that
understand how that's linked to the
heating system or the tracking system to
get more efficiency and a better
experience in a room like this so I
think you did a great job actually of
connecting to the urban environment you
know we're not talking about just the
technology we're talking about the role
of it
in the environment and another one of
our assets here at CMU jolt R has done
Studies on how lighting changed the way
we behave in cities when we first got
electrification so that's that's a big
difference what do you see as the future
what's different in a city not just
visually but performative lis because
we're implementing new technologies yeah
and there's multiple layers to that I
think one of the things you just alluded
to and we've done some of our own
research and partnered with some
educational establishments around the
world to understand the impact of light
on our lives and you know as a next
Northern European that has the benefit
of living in California for the last
couple of years I can just tell you
personally right you know you wake up in
dreary wet old England and it's never
like that here I enjoyed my drive here
this morning but you know contrast that
to being you know vitamin D over
overdosed in California you know you
wake up with an energy right so think
about to your point okay if you don't
have the benefit of good old California
weather how can you use light to change
that environment and Literary we've done
we've done studies and now some of our
connected lighting will literally do
that right so and we're actually trying
to figure out what the transition from
getting up in the morning all the way to
going to work is so our hue system has
been designed to be bright and
energizing when you wake up to be
relaxing when you when you come in but
to be intense enough if you want to read
a good book take that into the the the
war the the business world for a minute
or the educational mode for that matter
you know we're probably all drinking a
little too much caffeine nowadays to try
and keep that energy going
well what about using light to stimulate
and keep your brain and the endorphins
moving in the right direction so and I
think that just moves into the community
as well right and so the idea of
connected lighting in a city has
multiple effects one bring light to
impoverished areas bring light
efficiency by able to control those
lights but don't do it at the expense of
the experience we had a cardiff city
small city in south wales the capital
actually at our leadership conference a
couple weeks ago and
the gentleman was fantastic because he
talked about the benefit of a connected
light system but even he didn't didn't
understand so the idea is we're trying
to conserve energy but if there's an
accident can you give police access to
that system to turn up the lights to
bring safety in get people out get the
thing cleared up and then drop it down
again you know if you're at a restaurant
at a you know having a nice dinner on
your anniversary you don't want a light
just going in there so they've given
retail establishments access to the
lighting so they can dull it during that
peak hours but then when they want to
get everyone home safely they turn it up
brightly again and people get out of
that city so I think there's really
interesting sort of community benefits
and impacts and the one final one I'll
talk about which I'd even think about is
the benefit of light to the deaf and
blind community people in Cardiff go
down the pub and have a drink if they're
if they're if they if they're using sign
language they can communicate in an
environment like that as soon as they
work out and there's bad light they come
yeah you know blind people they don't
need light but their guide dogs need
light to be safe to take them home so
it's just a fascinating example of what
connected lighting has multiple benefits
in a community so that makes me think
about how important it is here in the
university that we already do a good job
working across units and I'm reminded
that our colleagues that came up just
before this presentation were from the
humanities and you know you heard more
than once that that part of their role
is understanding how this is situated in
the cultural ethical matrix of things
we're we're technological optimists
you're a technological optimists what
what concerns or worries or challenges
do you think we have with as we're so
optimistic about adopting new
technologies yeah that's a great
question we're just having this
conversation on the walk over actually
because I do i class myself as a digital
optimist
I'll put an a plug to plug in for a
gentleman that I don't know that well
but Peter Diamandis wrote this book
abundant so you've seen it it's it's
it's it's called the future as brighter
than you think nothing to do with
lighting at all by the way but it just
talks about digital adoption solving
some of these things we worry about so I
think one you know digital optimist
shouldn't be naive
to digital implementation because if
there's one thing that does slow the
benefits of digital it is the adoption
and again I'll pick on your background
cuz you know it very well right you know
the design and build infrastructure
business runs with a certain cadence and
a certain dynamic we touched on before
this about you know if people someone's
building this and and you guys say okay
I need a hundred lights in this in this
light bulb there's pressure on that
building project to do it at the most
cost-effective area so if you're not
careful the value of connected lighting
suddenly goes out the window we always
we are we also talked about a little bit
of the challenges of some of these low
cost imports coming in and are they
really delivering the value that people
think you know as consumers we're very
price conscious you know you could argue
that's what made Walmart so successful
right but the best product the right
place for the right location but you've
got to be careful is the value really in
that you know my father-in-law before I
even joyful it's lighting offered to
upgrade my lighting system at my home
and in my landscape and and I was
thrilled god bless him he got online he
did all this research all these boxes
started showing up did the whole thing
less than a year later fifty percent of
those lights don't work
yeah so thinking through that whole
value proposition and so the
implementation side and really
understanding the value and therefore
the idea of collaborating across silos
is something that should not be
underestimated that is easier said than
done
absolutely so we now have time for
questions from the audience and I know
that you can text them in the
instructions are on your tabletop so you
open up a website and then you just ask
your questions and Anna you've been
monitoring those questions what do you
want to throw our way a lot of questions
okay you know and I want to apologize in
advance we're not gonna be able to get
to all of them but wanted to let you
know that so a question about privacy so
does the idea of connectivity also push
the idea of increased protection of
privacy and how our innovative companies
like Philips thinking about this issue a
very excellent topic and fairly topical
in the news this week with a mr.
Zuckerberg and what Facebook are doing
and it's interesting I had a white
court session with the the mayor of San
Juan this morning and she just
passionately was drought drawing up what
she needs from a new infrastructure and
two parts of the conversation which I
thought was fascinating was one how do
we make it all digital but then the
immediate follow-on question needs to be
how do you make it securely digital and
if we're not careful we are putting
digital solutions all over the place and
security is a little bit of an
afterthought and we don't really stress
test the security of those so one it's a
security as a fundamental and to
candidly I think digital optimists
shouldn't get carried away to themselves
they've got to understand the community
that they are there talking to and
addressing and you know privacy security
concerns if they're real issues but I
think we've got to correct the right
right balance you know the analogy I
always use is you know people used to
walk in front of the automobile with a
flag slowing it down as well right we
eventually got comfortable with the
automobile and decided to put speed
limits on freeways so there's this sort
of an adoption process we need to think
through I know you got a lot of
questions so I'll try to make the
answers quicker so I know that you and
the mayor of San Juan talked about
life.i which shows a lot of promise
so does Phillips have plans to work with
the device market laptops and phones to
integrate Wi-Fi hardware in their
products I think the quick answer is yes
and obviously we're excited about the
future opportunity we also feel you've
got to be careful with some of these new
technologies they're not a panacea to
every connectivity issue what you're
seeing now with life.i with
next-generation Wi-Fi narrowband IOT you
know Bluetooth ZigBee there's multiple
connectivity options now so you've got
to just think through where is that best
suited to the best use case next
question can you talk about energy for
enabling the computing this person is
worried that all of the energy gains
that we've gotten from switching to LEDs
would get lost in the in the race to
remain connected that's an excellent
question and I think this is where the
the not just the design community but
the user community the people that
operate these things need to be thinking
it through however even with LED
technology we haven't
they implemented a tremendous amount of
sensor technology so you know even LEDs
can get left on and so I think the
combination of a correctly architectured
digital environment with the remote
amount of sensors can hopefully stay
ahead of that curve right so next
question as the developing world grows
what are the challenges Phillip sees in
the future of the lighting industry boy
that's a good one challenges in the
lighting industry and specifically one
lighting like many industries always has
a pressure of commoditization and I
touched on it earlier right you know the
the the the the low pressure point of
cost you've got to think through not
cost but value so on the one hand we are
committed to the lamp business the LED
business we're going to be in the
lighting business for a long time but we
also recognize in fact we made an
announcement just to two weeks ago that
our entire product line will be either
connected or connectable within the next
three to five years so we believe the
connected side is going to help us with
a commodity side because of all the
benefits we've talked about you
mentioned that you are devoting five
percent towards R&D so how much of a
commitment do you have with venture
funding we don't actually publicly
announce that and actually the good news
is it's a growing number and as a public
company I think where we're noticing and
conferences like this a great examples
of realizing that startup community can
help us move faster and cover more bases
so now we've got an act an active our
acquisition strategy partnership
strategy I mentioned American towers we
actually have a partnership with my old
company Cisco we're going to be
announcing a number of other companies
so you've touched on this ecosystem play
I think the good news is Philips is
pretty grounded and realizing we're
going to do lighting and connected
lighting very well but it is going to
take a proverbial village to to deliver
all these all these benefits so related
to that what would you like to see as
signifies unique innovation 50 years
from now Oh
you are it's a great question it's a
great thought-provoking question you
know when people ask me questions like
that I actually have a sort of an
immediate pragmatic swing back to if we
could do if we could just deliver what
we're all talking about that makes this
world incredibly safe incredibly
connected you know hopefully you know we
can feed everyone we can educate
everyone and so I don't think there's
any magic bullet behind that I think if
we can just roll our sleeves up and get
get on and do some of the stuff that's
already done
we could see fantastic you know we don't
have to wait 50 years for the benefit we
can get on with it
so are you seeing an impact between
light frequencies and health and
motivational feeling so the quick answer
is yes and I touched on it before there
is definitely depends what the question
is so light frequencies and the impact
of light obviously how you use light
right if we build this light down off
the lunch it's probably not the best
strategy from a meeting perspective so
trying to increase the light gradually
that doesn't scare us either so there's
there's definitely and we're trying to
figure out again how we work with the
design community the operating community
to to make that a reality you can do it
today but we're not we don't have the
Opera House you know how many people
have been in a meeting room with this
beautiful there's one right over there
right gorgeous control panel on the wall
to do all these cool things and it
reminds me back and I'll share my ate
you know show my age here a little bit
it's good it's good old VCR days right
you know there's a VCR sitting on your
TV and that the lights flashing because
no one knows how to program that the
damn little clock you know is I
guarantee there's probably more power in
that panel than in the Space Shuttle in
Apollo 13 but can someone come in and
help us use a tech thing right so we've
got to make it and give Apple a lot of
credits right a lot and big fan of
apples you know no user manual an app
that makes it work hopefully we can
adopt it and use the benefits more you
know maybe I can just ask a question
that I've had is with that is what what
concerns do you have about the Sun
setting of operating systems
and being able to if I switch my phone
if I switch my software and I've got all
my hardware connected to that how do you
future-proof against that I you know
it's it's a great question I'm not sure
I have the right answer and I you know I
hope especially my old tech industry
gets better better and better at that
because on the one hand it's easy for
tech companies to go do it in fact
there's a great one line it's like why
was a why was God have it to build the
world in seven days because there was no
infrastructure to upgrade you know and
it was you know and I think tech
companies kind of cheat a little bit say
I'll forget that infrastructure don't go
with them go with a new one
yeah so I know we're getting a hook a
little bit you have one last question
just one last question it was that for
me though we have students in the room
so give us a couple of last thoughts for
our students your future employees tell
us what you'd like for us to know yeah
come join us in help I think is the
quickest reminded it's that but in all
seriousness no it's a you know we we
need we need bright smart minds I just
had a meeting down in Argentina with
some of our early and career people and
my goodness the passion the energy the
the openness to adopting future things
versus candidly a lot of you know
companies are like well we couldn't do
that you know we haven't done that 400
yeah we've done this the same way for
100 years so one I think it's that to
think about the application of whatever
you're studying and doing into whatever
you're passionate about the private
sector the public sector philanthropic
areas you know whether you're into
engineering computer science you know
humanities think about all the good
stuff you learn how can you take that
out and make an impact and don't let the
company including a Philips
suck that out of you and try and make
you conform to the good old ways that it
got done we need bright motivated people
to help change the world and adopt this
technology faster than we do it the
normal way great thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]